frightening storm that hit the Dallas
Fort Worth area yesterday strong winds
ripping the facade off this car
dealership as large hail battered
vehicles and smashed their Windows the
wind gusted more than 60 miles an hour
and actually flipped this 18-wheeler on
its side in a parking lot outside Fort
Worth with two people inside fortunately
they were not hurt the national weather
service will be surveying damage in the
Irving area today for a possible tornado
you can see the funnel cloud spotted
over Dallas from the very same Cell It's
A system that caused a lot of damage and
is still moving across the Gulf Coast
right now